ladies and gentlemen the enemy is
committed to detonating a nuclear device
in an American city unless we act now
Elizabeth you're confident these men
will be at this place at this time I am
so let's go understand
amazing work I knew I could count on you
students
we are honored to have secured the
talents of one of the most brilliant
minds in American foreign policy today I
resigned my post four years ago after
that I was a figure of controversy thank
you for your service to the country how
many people died how many maybe you
should do this yourself one of the times
right why are you here
I just want to understand how evil works
you understand
hate it we were at war we did what
needed to be done and our country is
safer for it these have to be published
there are elements within the White
House who we make sure these never see
the light of day decision was made and
order was given near the with us here
against us it's as simple as that
what should we do with let me take
I'm no longer on your team
are you suspicious of everyone now
we have to win this war total victory
[Music]
I know I'm gonna have to answer for what
I've done
but I have a chance
[Music]
you